before we get stuck into the main
menu we've got these two different
shapes here and this is where it starts
to get as you saw
from our early lessons last week you
like go from oh just lines
and circles and that kind of thing into
more unusual sort of stuff on the
complex plane
so we've got this over here which if you
recall
there's kind of a part of this uh graph
that's implied um which
this is perfect but there's sort of this
interval in between right
and so to get your shape which sugar is
sort of flawlessly graphed
and we extend that interval out to
infinity in both directions
uh what is that called by the way when
you've got this extension here but
there's a defined start point
is that chord starts with an r that's a
ray right so intervals
start and end raise start but they
never end and their lines are infinity
in both directions okay so the axes are
lines not intervals or rays anyway so
you've got these and then you've got
these two spots what are the coordinates
of the two spots like this one in the
second quadrant what is that
have a look hopefully you graphed it to
start with right it's minus
two plus i right and
i would say it's 50 50 on whether you um
put it on the point
on the corners there or if you placed it
on the coordinate axis both
are unambiguous um i think i have a
minor preference for putting it in these
terms because
these are complex numbers right this is
the complex plane not
the cartesian plane but you totally like
you can see from
scale here that's perfect right and then
what's this other one this is one minus
three
i isn't it so important if you didn't do
this sort of automatically in your brain
often when you see minus signs like this
like i just don't trust myself right
so i want to get this into the form that
makes it most
easy to see what the reference point is
so my first line of working would have
been this
to get to us to minus 2 plus i if you
can you're happy doing that in your
brain
that's great just remember everything
that you do
mentally that isn't on your piece of
paper becomes that much harder to error
check if you're going back and have you
look like did i do this right i don't
know
my brain seemed happy with it before and
you've got you've not got a way to debug
what happened if something has gone
wrong
all right and then uh paris gave us this
region shaded over here
what do you think are you happy with it
can i get some thumbs up or some nods
yeah okay happy
um there there are some things that i
want to point out here right we've got
this
uh circle here it's dotted why is it
dotted
yeah fantastic so as anyone said we're
not including the boundaries so
paris is right away like even before you
get to the second part
the second region inequality you have to
satisfy that's never going to be
included
and that implies by the way that there's
an extra piece of information which i
didn't ask for so it's a bit unfair
but you should always think of your
brain should go there whenever you're
doing things on the complex plane
there's a couple of boundary points here
right between the circle
and then this uh this region this kind
of like group that part of the graph
they're here and here this spot
and this spot okay now because paris
correctly put this as a dotted
circle to begin with right i already
know that these boundary points
are not included yeah does that make
sense like they can't be part of
the subset of the complex plane i'm
after what i don't know that
though are the coordinates of these
boundary points did anyone find them
anyone now i'm going to ask you right
now i'll give you i'll give you 60
seconds
i gave you nice arguments here to make
it actually quite easy to find
what those two boundary points are minus
pine four
pi on four so if you wanna think of it
this way the um
the ray going up into the first quadrant
right that has a really easy equation
because
a gradient of sorry gradient of pi on
four sorry an
angle of pi on 4 means a gradient of
that's 1 right it's halfway between
naught and pi on 2.
so therefore this line here and actually
would be helpful for you to graph this
again even though i didn't ask it
the equation of this line is y equals x
degree because that's it passes through
the origin gradient one
right um conversely you've got an
equation down here of y equals
negative x okay so therefore knowing
that y equals x the x and the y
coordinates the real and the imaginary
components of that point should be the
same in the time that i've been talking
to try and buy you time has anyone gone
and worked out where the corners are
four four route
four what's through four quadrant four
oh the the fourth root of okay
so i've got i've got one better does
anyone want to give me a
does everyone agree with that or do you
wanna give me a different number
four through of four i'm just a way of
writing it there is a much more
conventional way
fourth root of four um can we can we
simplify any further than the fourth
root of
four maybe i should write um this is
four to the power of a quarter
does that help you at all because i
don't know if you know your fourth roots
particularly well this is um
this is four to the power of a half to
the power of a half do you agree
in next laws what's four to the power of
a half again
that's two to the power of a half so
this is square root of two right
it is a bit of an unconvenient but it's
fine it's i mean it's correct okay
so root two but what what do i do with
that like root two
the number is just on the real axis so
i'm clearly not in the real axis here
root okay great so let's uh let's fix
this up a little bit so let's call this
one over here
root two plus root two i how would we
know whether we were right on it could
go to mod art form
if you wanted that seems like a rather
you know here's like a little
nail it's like let's take let's take an
anvil and put it on it right um
is there a simpler way than to go to mod
art form even though that would work
vern
pythagoras maybe year eight maths might
might just do the job for me
um which of course is a fancy way of
working out the modulus right
we know we know if we have a look we're
on y equals x because you're a real
component your imaginary component are
the same that's fine
but then i just want to work out well
okay does this satisfy this right angle
triangle here
is there not there always is whenever
you work out the modulus
there's always a right angle triangle
implied so you've got root 2
root 2 is the modulus going to be what i
want which is
4. can you do a squared plus b squared
in your head i think we can right root 2
squared
plus root 2 squared does indeed give me
4. so i'm happy with that um
it doesn't give me exactly the
coordinate down here though what's
what's this corner
i'll give you a quick it starts with
root two and then
minus root two i because it's the what's
that called starts with the c
it's the conjugate thank you very much
okay great so we've got boundary points
it's always going to be implied by the
way if they're nice to you they will say
show me all the boundary points show me
all the equations but even if they're
not explicitly asking you should do it
anyway emmanuel uh
i was just wondering do we have a open
circle
at four do we have an open circle at
four
this point here
what do we think is there an open circle
at four
who put an open circle at four who put
anything at four
most people it sounds like and when i
wandered around didn't put four
as a point which makes sense because not
necessarily an intersection point with
the region
but it's worth asking the question
anyway should it be an open circle or
not
is it already implied by the direct
circle isn't it already
implied by the dotted circle what does a
dotted circle this dotted circle mean
it means that's my boundary but i'm not
including any spot on that
circumference yeah so i guess that is
kind of shorthand
for putting hollow circles everywhere on
the circumference which would just take
forever
does that make sense does that answer
the question so that that entire region
there
dotted circle uh implies that it's not
included and then we go all the way over
here are you all right with that
do make sure and i think paris has just
gotten there you've got enough of your
complex plane
that you can clearly see what boundaries
sort of define it is that all right
okay well done go to that piece of paper
which i